hey what's up everyone and welcome to
battle damage on today's episode we're
gonna see how well this printer which
stands our three tests the HP Deskjet
2540 all-in-one can print scan and copy
but how tough is it built we're about to
find out there are three basic tests
here on battle damage drop from a normal
height drop from really high and finally
a random act of complete and utter
destruction and we'll be capturing it
all with our custom-built camera rig
all right let's speed all cameras action
like a bunch of broken Christmas oh yeah
oh so you think it still works
I think the scanning function might be
disabled yeah oh boy
action
that broke out let's put again looking
to me hahahaha
the glass survived I'm baffled but the
steam chatter how heavy is this handle
55 lb actions for you I'm gonna be
behind the glass I love it
here we go three two one go
like a space that's why it's armored
it's okay
well let's look to the printer hmm it's
under the ship under the Coxes apart is
that all right we smashed this printer
for science now it's your job to share
the video with your friends what do you
want to see us battle test in our next
episode we listen your comments leave
them down below or on social media with
the hashtag battle damage thanks for
watching